good morning everyone the topic of
today's webinar is covert 19 and
specifically the bioinformatics of
infectious diseases so we want to speak
today about how viral genomes that are
found in whole samples different hosts
how we can identify what can we learn
about their genomic similarity and what
kind of considerations do we have to
keep in mind when we study potential
host reservoirs of emerging viral
strains that can lead to a pandemic such
as the coded 19 this webinar is brought
to you by pine biotech we are a
biotechnology company that is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible we
do this by providing training and tools
that help people make discoveries using
next-generation sequencing and other
types of high-throughput
on its data in the context of this
webinar
we'll be looking at publicly available
genomic data talk in detail about some
of the tools that are required to use
such type of data and also highlight
several elements that can be studied to
understand
Zhora notic transmission so I hope that
everyone that is joining today is
already here
we will record this webinar and we will
provide recording of this webinar after
it's complete if you have any questions
about any of the topics that we're going
to be covering today I encourage you to
put your questions in the chat and we
will pause during specific breaks in the
presentation to address your comments
now to make sure that we will go through
this presentation in a time that we've
allocated we will try to respond to the
questions that we don't have time to
cover in the session later on so please
make sure to pay attention to the emails
coming from our team
unlike previous outbreaks the covert 19
epidemic brought with it a huge
collection of data that has been made
publicly available and accessible on
such repositories as the National Center
for Biotechnology information or NCBI in
fact if we look at the speed that this
data has been made available ad we will
find that covered 19 outbreak has
generated approximately five times more
full genomes compared to four previous
major outbreaks including SARS one of
2002 Ebola of 2014 as well as Zika and
MERS of 2015 so what you see on this
chart is the number of full assembled
genomes per month on average these are
primarily human hosts on NCBI a virus
database and what you can see is that if
we break this down here by year there is
definitely an acceleration as you can
see if SARS in 2002 from then from 2002
till now there's about 12 260 months on
average and in total we have 481 fully
assembled genomes that's an average two
point two genomes per month and as we
progress from there we get to all the
way to almost 25 genomes per month
because we have such a short time frame
so what this means is not necessarily
that the amount of data is so vastly
different but the speed at which this
data is produced and made accessible so
we see this as a result of accelerated
pace of sequencing availability
availability of next-generation
sequencing technologies throughout the
different locations in the world and
widespread appreciation of the accuracy
and detail that such data can provide us
so that we can study infectious diseases
and all of these factors have
contributed to a large number of life
scientists around the world that turned
to bioinformatics to try and make
of such data and what it can tell us
about these emerging pathogens so due to
this increased interest training in
bioinformatics is an important step to
start mining available data and
effectively utilized bioinformatics
tools to support methods and data types
that are provided in publicly and
publicly available repositories from
recent outbreaks we have designed a full
program and that is going to cover in a
comprehensive way bioinformatics
approaches for biologists clinician
students and researchers to be able to
effectively utilize bioinformatics
methods to study this kind of data the
program will provide hands-on training
using several different viruses as
examples and you can see here some of
those examples coronavirus flu Ebola
rhinovirus polio and others so you have
in chat there a link to this program if
you're interested and briefly to
introduce the program I'm just going to
talk about this specific session that it
has been extracted from some of the
similar topics that we will cover in the
program so we assembled a series of
short lectures that we offer as free
webinars specifically on the content on
the context of covered 19 but they have
been extracted from this full two month
long program we also had some previous
webinars that we held on this topic and
they're available on our YouTube channel
and we encourage you to review some of
those sessions if you're interested in
the origins and pathogenesis of coded
maintain and how to use some of the
Associated bioinformatics methods to
study this type of genomic and
transcriptomic data so in this session
we'll speak about SARS Cove - the SARS
coronavirus - and the disease that it
causes that can be characterized by a
set of very specific features and we can
call this process pathogenesis we will
discuss how sonic spillover or
transmission between animal hosts and
humans can explain some of these disease
characteristics and how determining the
origins of this disease can help inform
us on the dangers as well as prevention
measures that have to be considered in
the future and then finally we will
discuss some of the data sets tools and
specific considerations that link the
biology of viral origin in transmission
as well as replication including cell
entry and Oh Sato spaces and invasion of
the immune system that are significant
factors for vaccine design and antiviral
drug development and repurposing in a
recent publication titled SARS Cove to
work Ovid 19 by the numbers that was
published by a known bar on IV slum
holds Rob Phillips and Ron Milo from the
Weitzman Institute of Science University
of California Berkeley and California
Institute of Technology as well as the
Chan Zuckerberg bio hub we find a number
of kind of considerations that have been
extracted from a series of numbers
published in different and variety a
whole set of publications and they show
some of the characteristics of the novel
coronavirus
SARS Co v2 so some of the findings there
related to the genome of the virus and
some of them are related to other
factors considered for the pathogenesis
of the virus the viral entry and how it
can adapt between different hosts so
what we will see is that a lot of these
numbers come from publicly available
datasets and all of us can have access
to as well and we'll talk a little bit
more on how to find those datasets and
how to evaluate such numbers from a data
perspective using efficient
bioinformatics tools and how can we
develop a framework to study emerging
pathogens like SARS Cove to utilizing
some of the same tools used in such
publications
so during this session I will refer to a
collection of tools that are typically
used for such research we'll be
demonstrating a little bit of how some
of these tools can be utilized by
leveraging the ti-84 platform the
platform was developed by the talbert
bioinformatics Research Center at
University of Haifa in Israel and during
the program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases all participants
will have the opportunity to utilize
this cloud-based user-friendly and
intuitive bioinformatics platform to
understand the logic of such analysis
and then to understand how the same
tools could be deployed in different
environments or how the platform itself
could be used for detailed interrogation
of such data integration and
interpretation of such bioinformatics
analysis specifically the you the
utility of this platform is for large
datasets so you can compare several
genomes on your own computer but once
you get into the hundreds of genomes
that are available for these outbreaks
having a cloud-based environment is
going to play a big difference in how
flexible your design of your analysis
can be so some of the aspects of this
platform include analysis of RNA seek
data and the importance of RNA seek in
the context of viral studies is to be
able to process large-scale data that
has gene expression information on for
example cell response to viral infection
we will also talk about network analysis
and machine learning that could be used
for data mining and how to identify
specific gene sets as well as signaling
and expression pathways and how we can
study their variation across different
conditions these tools provide
flexibility and efficiency because they
combine the logic of analysis in other
words why we're selecting specific steps
in our pipeline as well as you can
easily try and use them for different
project datasets and so we've prepared
some curated
data sets what you see here is a
collection of cell line based
experiments that demonstrate the
differences in response of the cell
immune system the innate immunity to the
way that the virus replicates in
differents modifications of the virus so
we can really study complex
relationships and analyze this data
efficiently when we have access to such
tools today however we will speak a
little bit more about mutation variants
these mutation variants can be studied
by looking at a reference so we can
compare multiple genomes to a reference
or we can really organize them into
different groups and study variation
between groups and so some of those
important aspects are available under
the mutation variant section of the
platform that we will take a look at
today and we can organize these datasets
by different types of information that
we will look at today in the NCBI virus
database
these types of comparisons can really
help reveal important variation between
key protein domains that are important
for viral infection and can be different
between hosts and so we'll take one of
these examples today and kind of try to
replicate that kind of a study and see
what those results are going to show us
these differences can also be studied
from an evolutionary standpoint and that
means that we can study genome-wide or
protein specific variation that can
indicate a common origin or
characterized relationship and even
arrive at an evolutionary distance
between samples which of course is very
important in the context of origin right
how do we know of an origin we can study
the evolutionary relationship what came
from what and maybe a common host that
was the origin of two different strains
didn't reveal important information that
we can then leverage in our analysis
these relationships of course require
finding and collecting specific groups
of data that can answer these types of
questions with a high degree of
confidence so we will look today into
how such data can be found and validated
and used in an analysis that actually
you can be confident in to help with
this process we will also refer to a
number of online visualization tools
that you can use to speed up the process
of exploration right so it's important
to link these different levels of
information starting from genomic
variants to the proteins and understand
the relationship between nucleotide
level amino acid level and protein level
information that really reveals the
significant areas that we should focus
on in the analysis we'll also take a
look at how an advanced comparison
between multiple hosts can reveal those
types of areas where we might focus in
terms of downstream steps of
characterizing and infection process
finding important areas for different
protein domains and then
so understanding the factors related to
that process other tools that we will
not be able to use in this session but
we'll discuss them in the future
provide the capability of using this
detailed data from controlled
experiments to use mathematical modeling
and simulation for the study of virus
specific processes such as replication
such in silico studies can help identify
important factors that affect
replication interference and outcomes of
viral infection the data from these
experiments can vary significantly and
can include next-generation sequencing
but also cell mites microscopy and even
animal studies where high-throughput
data requires automated technologies to
find and quantify the characteristic
patterns and finally a lot of these
datasets will point to a whole area of
in silico drug design where molecular
structures and their physical chemical
characteristics can be compared at the
structural level and are going to be
important for both vaccine and antiviral
drug design so our team is working with
several collaborators to continue to
expand the way such methods are
incorporated into our online platform
and could be utilized effectively even
for people that do not have a
significant engineering background so to
start learning about some of these tools
and some of these methods we've prepared
a collection of online resources that
could be studied for free some of them
priced very low for anyone to be able to
understand how some of these tools are
applied to different types of data and
genomic transcriptomic metagenomic data
and also leveraging the tools and the
online materials we design these
specific specialization tracks for
programs including this upcoming program
the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases so if you're interested to
learn about all of these different
aspects of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases we welcome you to join this
upcoming program and you can start the
registration process by visiting the
link that Leapster has placed in chat
with their pre registration form
okay so now let's start talking
specifically about covert 19 the novel
coronavirus also called SARS CoV 2 it
has emerged unexpectedly sometime in
2019 and was first identified in China
but also this is by far not the first
coronavirus that caused major concerns
concerns about coronaviruses have
emerged previously and good examples of
those previous outbreaks of our SARS and
Mars that have significantly lower in
fact ibbity rates but much higher
mortality rates for example MERS has a
fatality rate of 34 to 35 percent SARS
10 to 11 percent and SARS CoV 2 between
3 & 4 perhaps even lower as we have
larger sample size today of testing so
many people compared originally SRC will
be to the flu but we can see here that
this virus is also very different from
this from the flu virus in terms of its
epidemiological characteristics so let's
try to understand how these
characteristics could be found in data
and we have a question here does the
Cobra 19 BIOS change the genetic
composition according to their host it's
a great question we'll get to that in
just a second so the way that this virus
causes disease is what commonly is known
as a RTS acute respiratory distress
syndrome in SARS we also find the same
letters obviously an acute respiratory
syndrome and and this respiratory
distress is caused by accumulation of
fluid and cellular debris in lung
alveoli where the lungs bring blood to
facilitate exchange of co2 and oxygen
the rapid collapse of alveoli function
combined with the strong immune response
the virus causes makes this condition
acute so recently publication started
showing additional aspects of stars
infection
these reports point to infiltration of
the immune cells by SARS CoV 2 virus and
what's
called a cytokine storm caused by the
inflammatory response such response is
unusual for respiratory viruses and is
more closely associated with viruses
that target in the u n-- cells such as
HIV this by this actually comes from an
article published in Nature on April 6
in just recently a couple of review
articles so one of the questions that we
can start thinking about in the context
of this unusual corona virus is how does
this family of corona viruses and the
specific strains of corona viruses
differ between different animal hosts
where they might potentially originate
from and we can look at the question
that was proposed by IBM nyle kumar here
does the köppen 19 virus change the
genetic composition according to the
host right so I think a very interesting
question but what other elements do we
need to consider about these hosts so
the differences between these hosts
could be measured at different levels
obviously they are different in size
they have different metabolic processes
for example bats have much higher and
faster metabolism than humans they have
also a different immune response and
that means that they possess their own
microbiome their own environment of
microbes that include viruses and we can
see how the different stresses that they
put on the different pathogens that they
might carry actually help shape those
different genetic compositions that we
will look at in the context of corona
viruses in animals and corona viruses as
they interact with the humans so to
start talking about this let's just
define kind of what are these members of
the corona virus family so corona
viruses are members of the subfamily
corona VIP in the family corona verde
and the common human of Corona viruses
include types 229 e ml 63
Oh c43 in HK you won you can see some of
those right here a lot of these usually
cause mild to moderate upper respiratory
tract illnesses like the common cold
most people get infected with one or
more of these viruses at some point of
their lives right so what's important
here is that potentially all of us here
in this webinar have had an interaction
with the spires at some point in our
lives based on the phylogenetic
relationship and genomic composition or
structure of the cove at 19 it belongs
which beta corona virus which has a
close similarity of code at 19 between
code 19 to the severe acute respiratory
syndrome related corona virus or start
SARS one and ours outbreak the corona
virus study group of the international
committee on taxonomy of viruses turned
the virus SARS Co v2 and the
understanding of the genetic and
phenotypic structure of code 19 in
Genesis is important for our ability to
produce drugs and vaccines so
understanding the relationships between
these different strains and species of
viruses is going to be very important
for us to understand how to prove that
such an outbreak in the future how to
appropriately respond and how to learn
from this data that is being collected
so that in the future our response could
be more rapid and more effective viruses
as you can see they do not infect humans
but they primarily infect different
animals from bovine cows and and animals
like that to feline for example cats too
for example bats and penguins but all of
these are ma'am mammals right and so
what's common between these mammals is
that they all have specific cell
receptors that allow this virus to enter
inside the cell and utilize in cellular
Machinery to produce itself to replicate
and so we will look today at how
specific entry points into the cell are
key to the understanding of transmission
between the different hosts so to speak
about that let's talk briefly about the
genome coronaviruses possesses the
largest genomes that are between 26
kilobases and 31 kilobases which means
26,000 nucleotides to about 30 1.7
nucleotides this is the longest among
all known RNA viruses with GC content
nearly from 32 to 43 percent variable
numbers of small ORF s so you will see
here that there is a holy protein and
different open reading frames ORF
are present between the various conserve
genes so these are or f1 a B spike
envelope membrane and nucleo capsid and
in downstream to the nuclear caps gene
and different coronaviruses lineages so
SARS
0 v 2 has a single strand positive sense
RNA genome that codes for 10 genes
ultimately producing 26 proteins
according to the NCBA NCBI annotation so
how can it be that parent genes code for
over 20 proteins one long gene or one a
B encodes a poly protein that is cleaved
into 16 proteins by proteases that are
themselves part of the poly protein so
in other words this section right here
poly protein can be cleaved into
multiple elements multiple portions of
the protein by proteases that are also
encoded in this sequence sorry there are
some questions here does the global
warming have a role in appearing in this
virus does the sequence of stars still
be - in humans of different geographical
areas and same or not so this is very
important I think for us to talk about
in the future I think you know
some of the importance of the
environment is something we will look at
we'll also look at how to study
differences and take a look at where we
can find data so definitely we'll
address this as well in a few minutes so
these genes right so let's briefly speak
about the genes that are produced by
this genome the remaining genes
predominantly code for structural
components of the virus the spike
protein which binds to the cognate
receptor on a human or animal cell a
nucleoprotein that packages the genome
and to membrane-bound proteins too
though much current work is centered on
understanding of the role of accessory
proteins in the viral life cycle we
estimate that it's currently impossible
to ascribe clear biochemical or
structural functions to only about half
of Sarcee ob2 gene products so what's
important to understand about single
strands RNA viruses right here is that
they have a very high mutation rate and
so the remarkable capacity of some of
these viruses to adapt to new hosts and
environments is highly dependent on
their ability to generate de novo
diversity in a short period of time
right so this is a rate of mutation
rates of spontaneous mutation very amply
among viruses RNA viruses mutate faster
than DNA viruses single-stranded viruses
mutate faster than double-strand viruses
and genome size appears to correlate
negatively with mutation rate so that
means that the longer the genome the
short order the mutation rate viral
mutation rates are modulated at
different levels including polymerase
fidelity sequence context template
secondary structure or cellular of micro
environment replication mechanisms
proofreading and access to posts
replicative repair
additionally massive numbers of
mutations can be introduced by some
virus and coded diversity generating
elements as well as by host and codon
cited dean adenine the immunizes
our current knowledge of violet
rates indicates that viral genetic
diversity is determined by multiple
virus and host dependent processes and
that viral mutation rates can involve in
response to specific selective pressures
right you remember we were talking about
differences between animal and human
hosts and what we know today is that
those different host environments at the
cell and at the organism level produce
different pressures on the virus to
utilize this mechanism of mutation and
so as we will see this these different
pressures can actually produce a virus
that is highly infectious in the absence
of those specific mechanisms that
suppress replication in a specific virus
so studying viral evolution researchers
commonly use two measures describing the
rate of genomic change the first is
evolutionary rate which is defined as
the average number of substitutions that
become fixed per year in strains of the
virus given in units of mutations per
site per year the second is the mutation
rate which is the number of
substitutions per site for replication
cycle and so one is per year how many
changes accumulate per year another one
is how many accumulate per replication
cycle and so how can we relate these two
values if we have a single site at the
end of the year the only measurement of
a mutation rate in a beta coronavirus
justice suggests that this site will
accumulate ten to the third hours and so
there are 10 cycles per year multiplying
the mutation rate by the number of
replications and neglecting the
potential effect of evolutionary
selection and drift we arrive at 10 to
the minus 2 the third mutations per site
per year consistent with the
evolutionary rate confirmed from
sequence coronavirus genome so again we
can look at these genomes to estimate
the rate of mutation and so we see that
this virus undergoes a near continuous
replication in the wild consistently
generating new mutations that accumulate
over the course of the year so in other
words we
we'll see
we will see that the virus is
continuously changing in hosts different
hosts are producing different rates of
mutation and that's how we can study the
origin of the virus so let's consider
this question what is the origin of the
novel coronavirus by looking at how
these different processes of mutations
per replication cycle as well as the
sudden transitions between hosts can
potentially explain how this virus
originated so we have the original
genome that was published in that
represents the novel coronavirus SARS -
we have the sequence of the full genome
and we have the specific genes that
encode for different probe proteins and
we have a hypothesis write the
hypothesis again we are taking this
hypothesis from published paper that we
have our CoV - that is similar
phylogenetically to a common SARS one
bat SARS one corona virus so we suspect
the bat to be the primary host because
it is a reservoir of different viruses
that are known to have appeared in the
past like with SARS and other corona
viruses and we suspect that there might
be an indirect another link in the
transmission and the intermediate host
and we'll talk about how do we find
those and how do we evaluate the reasons
behind these types of conclusions so the
publication that we will follow to
answer this question is to compare the
novel coronavirus genome sequence to
other genomes coming from these
different hosts we will specifically
follow a publication that was published
in March in Nature Medicine by a number
of authors that took you can see here a
very specific collection of we notice a
couple from human hosts so
we have the SARS CoV 2 and the SARS CoV
so the original stars in the novel stars
three genomes from bats and one from
penguin and you will see how we can
study the relationship between these
different viral genomes at the whole
genome level which is here the
nucleotide whole genome level as well as
then specifically in area is of interest
because we understand the biology of the
viral replication we will also utilize
our knowledge of how viruses are
engineered and how viruses
typically come from hosts and or spread
between hosts to really make sure that
our theory or hypothesis and the answer
that we provide to support that
hypothesis makes both biological as well
as data sense so where do these viral
genome sequences come from genomes are
assembled from next-generation
sequencing which is typically done using
a process called shotgun sequencing the
process includes shattering the source
material in their RNA or DNA and then
sequencing short reads that can range
between 30 and 300 base pairs in length
these sequences are then assembled into
a full genome by looking at a consensus
in nucleotide sequence in other words if
the sequence of reads all shows the
exact same letters they are considered
to be the consensus if there's a
disagreement the majority wins as a
result from a single isolate or a single
sample we can get the full sequence of a
viral genome that is most abundant in
that specific sale this process is
fairly accurate however it reduces the
diversity of potentially present
variations of the viral virus in each
sample to a single sequence so the more
samples we sequence the higher their
confidence that a strain has consistent
characteristics because we're always
going to be looking at this consensus
based on majority so after these
sequences are found sampled from
different hosts and then assembled into
a full sequence what we have
access to the majority of the data data
that we will have access to are these so
called assembled genomes and sorry there
is a question here from Alicia yes the
recording of this webinar will be
provided at the end we will email it to
everyone so you can see that here are
some examples of these novel coronavirus
sequences and you can see that we can
then organize the nucleotide sequence
into what's called genomic structure so
we will use the structure of specific
elements of this genome to then study
variation an approach to study this kind
of variation is called multiple sequence
alignment or MSA and what MSA stands for
is the alignment of three or more
biological sequences they could be
either protein sequences and amino acids
DNA or RNA in many cases the input set
of query sequences are assumed to have
an evolutionary relationship by which
they share a linkage and are descended
from a common ancestor from the
resulting multiple sequence alignment
sequence homology can be inferred and
phylogenetic analysis can be conducted
to assess the sequences shared
evolutionary origins so the relationship
is based on time of evolution from a
common origin and we know this by
knowing the rate of mutation that we
spoke about recently ok so a question
here why can't why we can't answer alter
the conformational changes in the cell
surface receptor so that the virus
doesn't recognize the receptor and
doesn't bind it well imagine you have
millions of cells in your body and you
want to change the receptor of all of
those cells obviously that's not
possible ok so now we'll talk about
specific molecules right so we have the
whole genome so let's start from the
whole genome and because we know that
the mutation rate happens at the
nucleotide level and so let's talk about
some of these mutations first to
understand what impact some of the
mutations will have so mutations point
mutations are essentially substitutions
insertions or deletions these are the
possible changes at a single nucleotide
level however they have a different
impact on the outcome because these
individual nucleotides code for codons
which are then used to make protein so
if we think of this as in the context
the the central dogma of molecular
biology from DNA transcription to mRNA
to then translation to protein we
typically have a gene that gene encodes
for a sequence of codons and those
codons are transferred to amino acid to
protein level right so we'll follow the
same idea and we'll see how these
different mutations that we looked at
here can produce different changes to
different amino acids and the
differences in amino acid structure as
well as physical chemical properties
help us think about the impact of a
single nucleotide mutation and
characterize them in terms of their
impact on the functionality and that's
where we want to focus when we talk
about pathogenesis because that's the
changing of the pathogenesis at the
functional level so we have this
trinucleotide combination that forms
different amino acids and based on these
relationships we can now form an
evolutionary relationship so for example
what is an evolutionary relationship and
how is it typically represented we have
present-day
species and we want to find the
relationship between the present-day
species by thinking of how are they
interrelated and assuming that there is
somewhere in the eye on observed data
some common origin where they might come
from and so we will see how we can
characterize the relationship between
these present base species samples that
we will take and we will take samples
from different hosts we will then look
at relationships that are characterized
as a phylogenetic tree
so for example you're probably all
familiar with next string a project that
combines all of the samples that are
being compiled from this outbreak and
some of the previous ones and a lot of
times what we will see is a phylogenetic
tree like this that demonstrates
relationships so here you can see
different hosts right bats if it's
chimpanzees dogs hedgehogs etc so we see
different hosts where they are coming
from which locations and how are they
related to each other right and you can
see that there's a very big diversity of
these different viral strains where do
we find this data how can you and I find
this data from publicly available
resources these are some of the datasets
found on virus ncbi virus repository
database so we'll take a look at that in
a second so here what kind of phenotypic
information do we have about these viral
strains we can know what strain they
belong to these are typically annotated
the country of origin host virus species
and what's important about this is the
GenBank accession number which is an ID
a sequence ID that we can then retrieve
both the genomic information as well as
the phenotypic information with the
metadata about this type of sequence so
let's take a look at where we can find
this we can go to this link let's go
there together just to take a look at
what could be found so we'll go to this
link and what you will see when you go
to this link is something that looks
like this and here you can go to search
by virus so here we will find a
collection of different data sets and we
can simply put in Corona and we will see
if you give it just a couple of minutes
a second sorry some of the options that
you can find and these could be beta
coronaviruses alpha
coronaviruses the whole family karana
verde or you can look at other types of
for example SARS CoV - right here so if
you're asking the question do these
fluencies differ between different
people in different locations or
different dates you can ask this
question by starting to analyze this
data if your question is could I find
different hosts again you have the
ability to take a different host level
and take a look at sequences from there
so obviously SARS CoV 2 would be
specific to human host but if you were
to choose the whole betta coronaviruses
you would also find the bat
coronaviruses so how do we then to
utilize this data and understand the
relationships a primary collection of
tools that we will use for this is found
in on the platform that we will just
briefly demonstrate so let's go to the
platform and I'll just do a quick demo
of what we can do to study these kinds
of viruses so what I'll do today is use
this section on virus quasi species and
we've prepared a number of these
collections of data that you can use to
understand how the different viruses are
related to each other and we can look
here at this demo so what we'll do is
we'll load up a collection of samples
then we will align them to each other
using multiple sequence alignment and
then we will build a phylogenetic tree
to understand how their evolutionary
related so we'll click on start here
after we load them we actually this is
study of
a human sample so we'll do that a letter
later session let's take this collection
of data from different hosts this is
exactly the same analysis that was done
in this paper then we will do multiple
sequence alignments it will align those
sequences to each other to identify
specific variation at the genomic level
at the nucleotide level we will convert
that information to amino acid level
information so that we can study
variation in codons some of them
producing silent mutations some of them
producing important mutations that
change the amino acid and then we will
compare different types of evolutionary
analyses so different approaches to
study evolutionary relationships to
really understand the relationship
between the samples at that evolutionary
level and to do that we'll also use this
approach of characterizing the different
trees that are produced by these methods
and selecting the best ones that fit the
data that we have again we just click on
end and we'll take a look here at the
result so in the meantime there's a
question what are the reasons that in
the same pandemic like code with 19
sequences of viruses are different
because it's been transferring from
human to human once it has been
transferred to the first human impacted
okay so let's we'll take a look at the
data here in a second and you know
instead of hypothesizing let's take a
look at what's really found in the data
okay so as a result we won't have a set
of output so these outputs could be
organized by the different methods that
show us the phylogenetic relationship
for example it's just download this and
look at the result here and what you can
see is the
French accession numbers right you
remember we talked about accession
numbers and then we have the reference
genome that we use as the reference and
then we organized them into different
groups right so group 2 group 1 group 3
group 4 right and then we can see the
distance from a common origin so by
quickly looking at these different
accession numbers we can link the
accession number to a phenotype to what
we know of the sample where it came from
for example and understand their
evolutionary relationships so let's take
a look at quickly
what are these elements in a
visualization ok so I think this will
make it clear as to what we are looking
at so what we took was a collection of
samples some of them are from MERS so
you can see that the orange ones are
MERS then the pink ones are SARS these
red ones are coded 19 and the green ones
are beta coronaviruses and then we did
multiple sequence alignments and here
the different colors indicate how rate
of mutation or accumulation of mutations
could be studied by bins so here you
have bin size of 500 nucleotides or bin
size of 250 nucleotides and you can see
a detailed characterization of change
based on a reference right so what is a
reference genome the reference genome
that we took is the coded 19 from Wuhan
wet market that was originally published
in January so here we can see the
difference for example is more
significant between kovat 19 which is
not different at all and for example
MERS right or we can see the difference
between less of a difference between
kovat 19 and SARS but this is a human
host
right so the question is could we
collect the right type of a comparison
from publicly available data to study
specifically the relationship between
the
hosts for example penguins bats cats etc
so the answer is yes the answer is that
we can go here and we can find specific
data from different types of corona
viruses that infect these different
animals as well as humans and study the
relationship at the nucleotide as well
as the amino acid level so let's just
quickly get there we'll get there step
by step so here you can see that we
perform such analysis as described in
this paper and what are they important
findings right so here's the same
phylogenetic tree that we reproduced
from the data that was collected from
NCBI what how can we interpret this data
right here so here we have SARS
coronavirus stars corona virus or Bonnie
so these are different original
SARS coronavirus --is here you can see
two bat coronaviruses here you have the
bat coronavirus rat g13 in which if we
look for this accession number we will
see that this is a very recent sample
from bats deposited in December 2019 and
here we have the Cova 19 that original
sample and you can see that they are
very closely related and fairly far
apart from other ones now with the
detailed characterization of these
differences the question is why right
how are they similar how are they
different so in this paper they pointed
out a specific section of the genome
that encodes for the spike glycoprotein
here you can see that spike glycoprotein
let me quickly show you where to find it
on the sequence navigator if you go to
protein compare and this is going to
take a little bit of time to load so I'm
going to let it load but here you will
be able to see the spike
protein
and the spike glycoprotein once you load
the surface you will be able to
appreciate the differences specifically
coming from the different mutations and
understand what are some of these
domains right so where are these
differences actually found so let's take
a look
how do we know protein function first of
all so how do we know that a specific
protein is important for a specific
function there are multiple ways of
studying and today we will focus on just
one but in the future I'll expand on
some of the other ways that we can study
this primarily we're going to be talking
at amino acid sequence of similarity
which we can look at similarity at the
nucleotide level in the whole genome or
the whole sequence of the protein or a
local a specific region specific domain
we can look at the genomic context so
for example what types of nucleotides
what types of amino acids is it
surrounded by or we can look at specific
features for example subcellular
location of the where that protein is
produced or a functional class so we'll
talk a little bit more about how we
actually do this but we have to remember
that actually the protein has a 3d
structure and that 3d structure has a
lot of information about what is its
function and what are some of the open
areas of that protein what are some of
the closed areas of that protein and
when we will take a look at some of the
mutations that we found we'll take a
look at what is there significant from a
3d structure perspective as well another
way of studying the impact of these
changes is to produce experimental data
and we have access to some experimental
data that we'll also discuss in the
context of the full program that
characterizes the differences in this 3d
structure or specific genomic elements
and produces real evidence of what
changes at the host cell level so why is
this or how exactly do we know this well
amino acids have different physical
chemical properties and those different
physical chemical physical chemical
properties define how they interact with
surrounding amino acids in the same
structure or other amino acids that they
bind to for example so if we think of
the structure of the spike lipoprotein
the spike glycoprotein has very specific
amino acids that are
decision on places where interacts or
does some functional element of its
function some feature that it is built
for and therefore we can look at the
changes in those types of amino acids
when we consider these relationships so
here you can see some of those mutations
that are found to be present between the
bat coronavirus rad g 13 and that first
original kovat 19 human sample so the
red ones represent the highly different
areas and the gray means that they are
conserved so first of all what you can
see here is that they are fairly
conserved right so the conservation
between the bat and the human is very
high however there's a specific region
on the top view so you can see the top
of this protein that has a lot of
variation so we'll talk a little bit
about what this variation means let me
quickly address some of your questions
here performing MSA what could be
reference genome any sequence from a
typical corona family or any other well
yeah it depends on the question that you
might ask right if you have a well
characterized genome for example you
have a genome from a well characterized
SARS one you might use that as a
reference if you want to understand the
difference between the novel and the rat
or the bat genome right you can take one
of those so it really depends on what
question you might want to ask of the
data
another question does phylogenetic
analysis with different sequences of
covered 19 available in ncbi database
and found to be lied in different clades
are they termed as variants clades
represent consensus between a group so
if you find defined groups that have
constant variation but that is common
between that group of samples eventually
over time those would be characterized
as clades right because you need enough
sample size
I'm another question I've heard that
coronaviruses may identify three types
of strains a B and C but is not matching
in India then which of coronaviruses is
there in India is that correct so first
of all you need to understand that the
number of samples that is available is
going to play a huge role in how these
different strains are identified up to
date there's not that many and so as
more data comes in we will better
understand the differences and how to
categorize them right now I think it's
safer to say that there are specific
nations found in different locations the
tens of those variations is what's that
question how significant is that
variation and what role does it actually
play so I think this context will help
you understand and then later on once
that data becomes available we can study
that data and come to those kinds of
conclusions so where are these
variations that we saw in the previous
slide so specifically those variations
are in what's called the receptor
binding domain so this is a part of the
h2 protein and you can see how the the
spike glycoprotein opens up and connects
to the receptor and the specific binding
domain is where we find a lot of that
variation so how does that process
actually happen this is an illustration
produced by folks from one end strong
that produced the Samsun software and
what they were able to produce is a nice
little animation of how the spike
glycoprotein opens up so you can see
that this is the top of the spike
lipoprotein this is kind of like it's at
an angle and you can see how the top one
of these opens up to actually connect to
the spike glycoprotein right so
essentially the virus hides that
receptor binding domain until it is
close to the h2 protein when it opens up
and then it binds and that receptor
binding causes modifications to despite
glycoprotein that we will talk about in
the context of the sequence and the
changes that we observe
so where do we find this receptor
binding domain you see it's highlighted
right here this whole protein is
separated into two different portions
the top s one subunit and the bottom has
two subunit so that's what you can see
right here the s wants to be unit and
the S to subdue 'not you can have you
can see here the poly basic cleavage
site which is how the top area is
connected to the bottom area and then
you can see the receptor binding domain
right here and so based on just several
differences in these specific areas
two little areas we can now think about
the relationship between the bat
coronavirus which has an overall
similarity hi second Linea writes whole
genome similarity of 98% to the human
Tsarskoe v2 however in these specific
regions the receptor binding domain and
the poly beta cleavage site it is a
little bit different and if it is
different how can we look at other
genomes that have higher single area you
can see that the higher similarity
between the human and the Pangolin is
specifically found in this receptor
binding domain so in other words we have
three main findings here one is the
humans are Co V 2 that is overall at the
whole genome level much closer to the
bat rachie 13 genome however
specifically at this region it is more
closely related to the Pangolin right so
you can see the similarity highlighted
here and because of that similarity we
can think of the Pinklon as an
intermediate host however as you are all
asking there is this whole data
collection from the outbreak data past
that transfer right so after the virus
came from different host
entered the human population and then
started evolving in the human population
so the question is can we use the same
approach to understand the human
population changes and the answer is yes
we'll reserve other projects that we've
prepared to study some of these ideas
for our next sessions and let me briefly
outline some of these topics that we
will cover so the first example that we
will use is identification of how these
different viral genomes so you can see
here and we will take a look in greater
detail right at how these different
genomes are related and where they are
dissimilar we will also take a look at
different aspects of despite
glycoprotein including how this whole
cell entry or endocytosis happens as
well as how this protein can invade the
immune response and how it causes
specific acute chronic reaction at the
nating level to do that we'll also take
a look at previous SARS infection where
they took several different aspects of
the or one a B poly protein modified
them and studied changes in the cell
host response all of these projects and
many more of such studies and examples
are going to be available like I said in
different areas of bioinformatics for
infectious diseases and here I just want
to mention that we have partners in Sri
Lanka in India
and in Nigeria where such programs are
being planned right now
some of those links to those programs if
you're from one of those areas are
available so let me just post a couple
of those programs if you are in Sri
Lanka or in India you can look at a
couple of these links sorry and just
post in that to the wrong person but we
also have an online program that is
going to be open to everyone
in the US and in Europe so please please
look at those links again sorry for some
of the questions I didn't have time to
look at everything so the question from
dr. Amer as Abe is let me find your
question or maybe you could point out
what the question is a goodnights okay
if human can transfer the virus to
filling cats because of age - what
prevents the vice versa infection so
indeed one of the biggest concerns is
that we have silent carriers right so we
have carriers like cats and or dogs that
have the virus and so the difference is
between hosts is we can detect viral RNA
that does not mean that that virus is
causing an infection or high levels of
replication at the functional level so
again remember that detection of
presence of a viral RNA in a host does
not mean that we can detect variants
which are the actual virus particles so
detection of viral viral RNA you know in
many of these hosts that he contain a
lot of viral RNA in their gut for
example but it destroys the virion
particle so I think when we speak about
transmission we are speaking about
transmission of not the viral RNA we're
speaking about the transmission of the
actual virus and that virus having the
capacity to cause disease or
pathogenesis right and so that is an
important factor in the cell entry that
we are describing here so multiple
factors can actually prevent that
process from happening between for
example pets at home or agricultural
animals and humans but it's not ruled
out right so previously we saw how
camels might have been a source of MERS
we
saw like you know avian flu right coming
from chickens and birds so there are
many ways and we have to look at very
specific sequences and very specific you
know transmission points to really
characterize that in detail I think it's
difficult to explain that in just a
couple of minutes hopefully that
explains and that'll better sorry I
didn't realize the question was there
okay
so again I just want to finish with the
invitation to the Spile informatics for
infectious diseases where a lot more
detail is going to be provided and the
important part of this program is it's
not going to be series of lectures these
are going to be sessions designed to
train you to do this type of analysis on
your own briefly I'll cover a couple of
sessions that we will use in the program
we will talk about next generation
sequencing basics how to understand the
data itself and how to map samples
directly from hosts before their
assembly to identify presence of
specific viruses we will also in detail
take a look at some of the multiple
sequence alignment considerations how
can we utilize different types of
multiple sequence alignment methods how
do they vary and what type of
information do they contain including
determination of substrates and
haplotypes we'll talk about preparing
and running your pipeline so how to make
sure that the data set that you collect
is rigorous it really represents a
condition a biological condition and
eliminate some of the technical
differences we'll talk about in the
context of different types of pandemics
as well so here you can see some data
from Ebola some data from coronaviruses
and how to really structure your
analysis to get rigorous results we'll
also talk about how do we interpret the
pipeline results so what are these
pipelines produce and where to look for
so that you can understand all of the
process and how to find for example
technical variation how to link between
different levels of data how
to understand the significance of your
findings we'll talk about the
differences between infection and
pandemic so we'll really talk about the
process of disease spread the process of
symptom onset the process of
characterization the disease called the
pathogenesis that includes viral
outbreaks like we talked about today but
also virus transmission within the human
population cell entry to tissue trumpism
and some of the other factors that we
need to consider it like immunity we'll
talk about disease progression and
outcomes so that we'll talk about how we
can find specific regions characterized
their evolution or entropy over time and
then look at specific regions that are
very important for the characterization
or how to fit that characterization of
disease with the nucleic acid sequence
dissimilarity entropy and other elements
and we'll also talk about how to prepare
a project of your own right so we will
actually talk about the different
projects that you can design and how to
take those projects from beginning to
the end writes over here we will talk
about mutation variant types we'll talk
about the different findings that have
enabled that have been enabled by
bioinformatics analysis and produced
vaccines and what are some of the
considerations around those vaccines and
their effectiveness we'll talk about how
to use network analysis and machine
learning for studying host pathogen
interaction
invasion from the host and immune
response and some of the other important
aspects and so what we hope as a result
of this project as a result of this
program you will be able to conduct
analysis yourself you'll be able to
present your findings to a community of
peers that are commonly interested in
the same topics and potentially
presented at different online
conferences and presentations and get
some feedback from real experts in this
domain to support this
program again like I'd mentioned before
we have a collection of tools that are
completely online so you don't have to
worry about having a server access at
your house you can use everything online
and you will also have access to some of
the basic information if you are
interested to study this at a deeper
level so again thank you everyone for
joining today hopefully we will repeat
this again soon and we will definitely
let you know and in the meantime we hope
to see you in the program again starting
on March 4th and we'll send you the
recording of this webinar as well
you
you
you